the entire family is back together it is
everything
the cast of jersey shore is back
together
and it's a whole situation
this is like brings us to a whole other
level on tuesday mtv
announced that jersey shore family
vacation will return with new episodes
on june
3rd ladies and gentlemen parties
here and in a sneak peek at the upcoming
season which will take place
in the poconos we see nicole snooki
polizzi
making a surprise return to the hit
reality show
where she takes a tumble right off the
stage during a family vacation
talent show
[Music]
ouch i'm good i'm all right
back in 2019 snooki announced she was
leaving the jersey shore
and in 2020 she explained why to e.t
it's really hard filming especially with
three kids my little one's eight months
so
it's just really hard to you know get
away from the three kids and try and
enjoy myself there's a lot of mom guilt
there um and it's just not the same for
me
and while snooki sat out season four it
looks like she's back
at least for a little bit just have fun
with it
and there's a whole lot more to
celebrate oh my god
i can't believe this like jenny j wow
farley's engagement to zach carpanello
that's the 35 year old showing off her
engagement bling
i love everything about this woman it's
the strongest woman i know
in every way i'm blush i need a drink
the reality star said yes back in
february
and in march she shared the news on
instagram
posting this pic from the sweet moment
her man popped the question
on the top of the empire state building
in new york city
she is my queen the two started dating
back in april 2019
and at the time j wow told et that their
connection
came at the perfect time i feel like it
was semi-instant right
it was perfect timing he took me out of
my birthday
and we stayed in touch every day after
of course
jenny filed for divorce from her ex
roger matthews
back in 2018 they share two children
six-year-old daughter milani and
five-year-old son grayson
and speaking of kids baby situation
the trailer for the upcoming season of
jersey shore family vacation
shows the moment mike the situation
sorrentino
shared the news with his castmates that
he and his wife lauren were expecting
and they even did a gender reveal
in december the two revealed that they
were having a baby boy
on instagram just a few weeks after they
announced they were expecting their
first child together
who's now due this month it's one of my
finest accomplishments back in 2019
mike and lauren told et that they were
still trying for kids
after healing from her heartbreaking
miscarriage
we kind of relied on our faith and we
looked at each other for support
we're going to keep trying we can't wait
till that happens
yeah we're very excited to start that
chapter and we're moving forward
baby news engagements listen
pauly d said it best
you